[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening everyone I'm Justin
Woodward co-founder of the media in the
exchange the mix and one of the
producers behind the gorilla collective
helping to organize the show alongside
our developer publishing colleagues and
our great friends at kind of funny we
appreciate everyone's support for the
show and tuning in it is going to be an
amazing experience but we also wanted to
put a positive message out into the
world during these uncertain times we
are all proud of what we've accomplished
thus far with the gorilla collective as
well as the message of being stronger
United but we cannot ignore the
tragedies of George Floyd Brianna Taylor
Ahmad R burry and the other black
victims of police brutality and racially
motivated violence last weekend we put
together the Black Voices in gaming
stream with the support of our partners
to share a positive message as well as
aid for those affected by the Cova 19
pandemic through the addition of a
charity supported by tilt off' i where
you can donate to the streams during the
show we will remind everyone ways that
they can donate through the links below
thanks for listening
supporting these movements stay safe and
enjoy the gorilla collective peace
[Music]
welcome to the gorilla collective a
three-day digital festival of game
announcements trailers and demos
streamed straight to you please welcome
your host Game Awards trending gamer
Greg Miller what's up everybody welcome
to day two of the gorilla collective
yesterday we ran you through more than
30 games and today well we're not giving
you a chance to catch your breath
we have ID and Xbox debuts developer
walkthroughs games giving back in so
much more in fact we've gone ahead and
bundled up today's titles so you can get
a big old rock block of your favorite
genres so without further ado action
adventure fans here are a bunch of world
premieres exclusive
[Music]
somewhere out amongst the Stars there is
a world teeming with life and beauty
but this world is dominated by a
terrible alien force the eternal
cylinder no one knows what it is or
where it came from they only know that
it cannot be stopped
but sometimes it is the smallest most
unassuming of creatures that managed to
find a way forward to survive they must
band together
mutate
adapt evolve and overcome but no matter
what they do one fact for me
the eternal cylinder cannot be stopped
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone and one has Mary Kim
director and metronomic I'm very excited
to be public the relic collected today
to show you our new rhythm infused
action-adventure game in Australian
media and Zook are part of an indie rock
band called bunkbed junction who must
use the power of rock to fight against
NSR a corrupt in deep right so we are on
our way to the next concert you will get
to meet a cause of characters assess all
the battles in North Korea roads are
quite different and you'll have to work
out how to overthrow each main boss by
in the case of psy you how do you defeat
something that isn't real
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Dave Goldfarb creative director with
the outsiders and yeah I mean make games
occasionally damn straight you do this
is Troy Baker Troy's a legendary actor
of video game and film and TV where
you're about to see here is an exclusive
peek of some pre pre alpha gameplay of
our upcoming game metal hail singer
the game is about this character coin
the unknown her journey to overturn the
rulership of hell she has a number of
tools to do that and one of the main
ones is the character that Droid plays
recalling a past who was also sort of a
a weapon this skull that sort of has
this capability to harness the power and
so on in addition to being the this this
weapon he's also this one Mary story
there's Minerva otherwise known as
divine abolish her
the whole thing could escape is that
doing captions on beat is rewarding in
some fashion it can increase your score
for one thing it also does stuff like
build up your ultimate also this is a
weird thing but when you're like kind of
maximum performance when the multiplier
of the tier is at its highest that's
when the the music builds and builds in
terms of like aggression and fullness
because these are these are basically
layered track so the vocals kick
you
what's happening everyone I'm Justin
Woodward co-founder of the media in the
exchange the mix and one of the
producers behind the gorilla collective
helping to organize the show alongside
our developer publishing colleagues and
our great friends at kind of funny we
appreciate everyone's support for the
show and tuning in it is going to be an
amazing experience but we also wanted to
put a positive message out into the
world during these uncertain times we
are all proud of what we've accomplished
thus far with the gorilla collective as
well as the message of being stronger
United but we cannot ignore the
tragedies of George Floyd Brianna Taylor
Ahmad R burry and the other black
victims of police brutality and racially
motivated violence last weekend we put
together the Black Voices in gaming
stream with the support of our partners
to share a positive message as well as
aid for those affected by the Cova 19
pandemic through the addition of a
charity supported by tilt off' i where
you can donate to the streams during the
show we will remind everyone ways that
they can donate through the links below
thanks for listening supporting these
movements stay safe and enjoy the
gorilla collective peace
[Music]
welcome to the gorilla collective a
three-day digital festival of game
announcements trailers and demos
streamed straight to you please welcome
your host Game Awards trending gamer
Greg Miller what's up everybody welcome
to day two of the gorilla collective
yesterday we ran you through more than
30 games and today well we're not giving
you a chance to catch your breath
we have ID and Xbox debuts developer
walkthroughs games giving back in so
much more in fact we've gone ahead and
bundled up today's titles so you can get
a big old rock block of your favorite
genres so without further ado action
adventure fans here are a bunch of world
premieres exclusive
[Music]
somewhere out amongst the Stars there is
a world teeming with life and beauty
but this world is dominated by a
terrible alien force the eternal
cylinder no one knows what it is or
where it came from they only know that
it cannot be stopped
but sometimes it is the smallest most
unassuming of creatures that managed to
find a way forward to survive they must
band together
mutate
adapt evolves
learn and overcome but no matter what
they do one fact for me
the eternal cylinder cannot be stopped
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone I'm one husband game
director and metronomic I'm very excited
to be public the relic collected today
to show you our new rhythm infused
action-adventure game no stray rules
alright welcome to vinyl city in this
game you control media and xilk maybe
and Zook are part of an indie rock band
called bunk bed Junction who must use
the power of rock to fight against NSR a
corrupt EDM Empire who has been rocked
from all forms of performances in the
city
each district in velocity is ruled by
different NSA artists from a globe
spinning DJ - robotic boy band and a
piano playing child prodigy as well you
can use the power of music to interview
objects in the environment as well
Acharya will open the door to access a
new area we are excited to see how you
will use your music to interact with
various items in the game right so we
are on our way to the next concept
you'll get to meet a cause of characters
as you explore velocity so be sure to
talk to them okay it's time to head
inside and meet side
saya is a digital Idol who visualizes
herself as a merman and while she looks
friendly she doesn't take kindly to me
dancing interrupting a concert all of
the battles in Austria roads are quite
different
and you'll have to work out how to
overthrow each main boss by in the case
of saya how do you defeat something that
isn't real that's just a small flavor of
nausea routes we can't wait for you to
see more of it very soon and bring rock
home when the game launches on internal
switch ps4 Xbox one and PC this summer
exclusive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Dave Goldfarb director with the
outsiders and yeah I mean make games
occasionally damn straight you do this
is Troy Baker Troy is a legendary actor
of video game and building TV where
you're about to see here is an exclusive
peek of some pre pre alpha gameplay of
our upcoming game metal Hale singer
now she's come back
the game is about this character on the
unknown her journey to overturn the
rulership of hell she has a number of
tools to do that and one of the main
ones is the character that Droid plays
with calling pass who's also sort of a a
weapon this skull that sort of has this
capability to harness the power and so
on addition to being the this this
weapon he's also this one Mary
story is Minerva otherwise known as
divine abolish her
the whole thing good escape is that
doing actions on beat is rewarding in
some fashion it can increase your score
for one thing it also does stuff like
build up your ultimate also this is a
weird thing but when you're like kind of
maximum performance when the multiplier
of the tier is at its highest that's
when the music builds and builds in
terms of like aggression and fullness
because these are these are basically
layered track so the vocals kick in at
this highest level
[Music]
the pirate number when you first talked
to me about your like so we're gonna
have this mechanic where we're using
music and I was like oh cool and I
didn't understand at first what you
meant by that and it wasn't until I
actually saw the gameplay almost says
like dude that's kind of cool how it
actually matches up to work like in time
you're like get it the whole point of
the game I was like oh that's it dude
just wake up
there's a certain rhythm to the way that
we play anyway so leaning into vadik
creating a mechanic around that to me
was like dad's what I already do it's
that level of emergence that good games
give us when they go we're gonna take
what you already want to do and we're
gonna build it out and allow you to do
more of it yeah I mean it's just it's
like a flow thing I think when I was
thinking about the concept I was like oh
that's it would be cool to do something
because I was playing think out of what
I was playing but I think something I'm
listening to Michigan killing stuff
gonna be and I was like this is cool
what I appreciate about this is that
yeah you've got this cool twist and
mechanic as far as like the rhythm and
the know how do you want to frame that
it's like the rhythm and the wreckage
you know yeah that's good but it's it
doesn't feel tacked on because it feels
endemic to the world because the way
that and I don't know which came first
if you if it sounded the mechanic think
came first and you kind of built the
world and a character around that but it
feels like it's it's it's um it makes
sense why there's a rhythm as opposed to
okay I just have to have a rhythm
because there's always that weird and we
always use this employ this phrase but
ludonarrative dissonance where it's like
well that I get that I get that the
world and the characters trying to do
that but but but there's actually a big
disconnect between the world that you
presented me with and the task that
you're giving me to do inside of that
world right so this to me it was like oh
I understand this is who she is and this
is why and this is why also she V is a V
I am a badass if I continue to do this
so well and it's just that even like in
the the UI of it there's so many things
that are encouraging me and and
rewarding me for being a badass the game
came out of like I knew that I won't do
that rhythm thing but then the character
of the unknown like immediately
sometimes you just know and it hasn't
happened to me very often so would you
say the unknown is is kind of still
that's the first draft that's stuck or
do you feel like you yeah wow that's
awesome it's dumb but as soon as I wrote
the name
I wrote the unknown and lit that's it
Wow and then everything else kind of
worked after that the time between you
going that's it and actually making work
is usually a extended period of
suffering visions come to prepared
spirits to me maybe that's not just like
oh I just had this idea for character
it's all the years that you've had as a
dev working an understanding character
it has put you in a place to go
here it is it feels momentary and it
feels like a came to you almost as a
vision but it's actually all of the
years that you have spent suffering and
family developing and understanding and
world building
yeah I mean all that stuff like that the
way that the music went up happening
like me being this crazy dynamic layered
thing you know all these vocals come in
and and stuff that actually came a
little later that was not even something
that we thought you could get to work
but the audio to you of course is bunch
of wizards and then the artists
themselves or Gontier so yeah we mean
definitely did a bunch of stuff that we
may be able to
[Music]
I don't know how quickly you assembled
this team but now you've got all of this
it's kind of coming together to it to
thing you actually you can now pick up a
controller and now play like seeing it
become tangible he's got to feel great
yeah it is but I just been working on
this thing for ten months or so I think
and the idea was just something in the
back of my head while I was working on
Darfur
you know and I and doctor we didn't work
out and then I was in this place where
it was like we could do this other thing
we have the knowledge I think here let's
give it a shot
Kidman luckily the team was really good
basically they made the best product
I've ever seen in like two or three
months and it was really clear like
something there's something there and I
think everybody just kind of placed
their bets that we would be able to
figure it out because it's new like
nobody had ever made anything there's
not many of us before we knew how to
make shooters so that's kind of where we
landed make sure that the shooting is
good make sure that the movement is good
and we'll figure out the rhythm stuff oh
it's time to the actual boss battle who
will feature Jen Hale
[Music]
honor the ball
[Music]
so the red judge what can be said well I
mean I don't wanna give anything away
however she is the she's the primary
antagonist the immovable wall to the
unknowns unstoppable force hey yeah
Joseph Campbell is just a ploy
anyway so she she's bad news and she she
and the unknown have some kind of
history that isn't or it's unknown no no
I'm joking
but she's the primary enemy for the
player and features prominently in all
these kind of all of the hell's and all
the progression so so so I want to get
on her bad side
and I'm sure John Hale will be happy to
talk about her at a later date Jin Hale
you know for all fans of Mass Effect
this is by the way not not hating on
male chef at femshep at the widow for me
to write it was something new and fresh
inside of that genre and just her
performance was like man I've had this
as the voice of the hero and so to hear
her play the juxtapose that to hear her
play a and an antagonist like you said
that the the immovable force is like yes
have the nerd in me like yeah that's
good and no she's really funny but she
does all these like voices and stuff on
them whatever you're doing sessions I've
heard I would never guess that was Jen
Hale and she didn't meet cute little
character voices that's the one yeah she
can do the kids characters those I have
no idea that came out it but her
creature sounds are and are just amazing
I should have asked her do creature
sounds a choice have been talking about
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this game every step of the way I've
just been constantly impressed and
excited to not only be a part of this
game but for the date when I can
actually finally sit down pick up the
controller and actually play this game
when is that oh wait I know it's uh it's
gonna be 2021 at some point get us out
of this year and let us celebrate this
game seriously that's just anything to
get out of this year so yes when we exit
this year your your your present
hopefully will include a vaccine and the
release of this product so that would be
a hell of a collector's edition by the
way if they say like you if you get sick
like this edition that also comes with
the vaccine this game will literally
save your life
[Applause]
hey man it's me Kevin Smith this goes
out to all you video gamers and video
game fans and video game developers and
video game makers and video game
enthusiasts and video game grand poobahs
and video game curious people out there
man thank you so much number one for
supporting my game Jay and Silent Bob
mall brawl I'm here to talk about 2d
games kids two-dimensional games they
got the one-dimensional person to talk
about two-dimensional games I grew up on
2d games I'm an Atari 2600 kid played a
lot of pitfall I love my side-scrollers
and whatnot once we entered the age of
the three dimensions or the FPS like
that that was too big for me it was like
taking acid and seeing the universe way
too big for me man I was cool with
side-scrolling people stopped Megan I lo
and behold they didn't because in the
indie game community they're still
making side-scrollers just like
interrobang made are Jay and Silent Bob
mall brawl and stuff like that so I
salute I support you indie game
developers out there thank you for
everyone who's still supporting games
and whatnot and let's be honest that's
everybody particularly at this time I
wanna I'm here to drop a bunch of 2d
titles on you and while I'm here we're
also gonna drop a trailer on you ladies
and gentlemen we're gonna show you the
trailer for our forthcoming video game
Jay and Silent Bob chronic blunt punch
that's right man that's it this game is
beautiful people haven't seen what this
looks like
it doesn't have the charming 8-bit
appearance that we have with mall brawl
this game the boys been working on
really really long and hard and stuff so
thanks for being here watching thanks
for being indie game developers in the
indie game fans game developers and game
fans thank you for making creative
things the creative choice two paths in
this world destruction and creation all
of us here choosing creation even though
we play games about destruction without
further ado here's a game about
destruction Jay and Silent Bob chronic
blunt punch
exclusive
[Music]
[Music]
Follow Me My dear creatures of Darkness
come I have witnessed such words
hi Chris from the xxx xxxx team here
today we're gonna talk about the games
deuteragonist ace the war relic a
thousand years have passed and ace is
back with some new tricks asa style
system gives him a wide array of new
techniques that he can weave together
fluid movement and devastating combos
his Styles include tax defenses and
movement tech so ace hasn't answered it
pretty much any sticky situation for
example with the Dolomites link here ace
can launch himself onto enemies
exploding and getting a jump boost while
he's airborne he can't be hurt by enemy
touch damage so he can always find a
safe landing it also works on stage
objects with the Zen ascent here ace has
a flaming uppercut that he can use in
midair for a little bit of extra height
and his reijin call lets him call down
the lightning from above and then shoot
it right back out
unlike Nina's energy cases style bar
recharges quickly so you don't really
have to worry about conserving energy
asus new systems have been a ton of fun
to build and I hope you're as excited to
try them out as I've been designing them
for more info check out the discord and
steam page info in the insight thank you
so much for watching stay home stay safe
and play video games
[Music]
exclusive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay hold on speed limit looked awesome
anyway let's go from that frantic
fast-paced crazy action to something a
bit more subdued a thinking persons pair
of genres if you will yes I'm talking
about plotting your move based on your
opponents and trying to romance a
character through your wit and
determination let's look at some
strategy games in RPGs exclusive welcome
to your Island Resort a perfect getaway
to while away the errors without a care
in the home wait no this is evil genius
- and this is a mere cover for a
nefarious
world domination No before we head to
rebellions underground HQ for a few
villainous announcements let's go on a
tour of the world's first gameplay
trailer that was Unleashed yesterday
with leap designer reg Edwards this is
evil genius - it is rebellions premier
world domination simulator where we're
inviting you to build your very own evil
there into an island paradise
the lair is made up of many different
kinds of rooms from the inner sanctum
where the genius will be plotting their
next move to the barracks where the
minions can rest and we gather their
strength for the next assault and the
Bhalla trees where mad science will take
place on a daily basis so who are these
guys are we in control of this lot
they're your work force they're the
people who obey your every whim and you
tell them what you want done and they
will do it so if you want a new room and
you're there you tell them where it
should be what size what it should look
like the things it should have in it and
they will go and do it for you we're
using something we call the route to
them you idiots paradigm we use the
genius are focused on the big picture
stuff and your minions worry about the
details I like the idea of having
minions but why are they so essential
here well the genius isn't going to do
everything themselves they need people
to do things for them for example it's
very rare to see a genius get so hands
on in their plans and instead rely on a
vast network of mooks goons folks to do
these things for them so for fans of the
original game do we have any new types
of menus
there's a few remixes in there that I'm
sure eagle-eyed fans will spot if they
watch the trailer closely there's a
whole bunch of minions that we are
actually bringing back from the original
[Music]
so henchmen seem a bit more important
who have we got here they are your
upper-class criminals and they serve you
directly so while some minion will go
away and do something for you a henchman
you can reach in and to give them
specific orders go and kill that agent
going into Harrogate this person you can
also utilize their special abilities
of which they have many and it looks
like we have a few to choose from we
have got a number of henchmen in evil
genius
they begin life as crime lords
originally opposed to the evil genius
but then you're the boss you'll be
bringing them into your own organization
so you'll be doing battle with their
criminal empire as the genius is up to
you to show them who's boss and make
them fall in line they're far more
competent than your average minions if
you want something done right you send
henchmen to go and do it we're giving
the player a greater measure of control
over these characters and that includes
being able to use their special
abilities
well speaking of people entering the
lair it's time for the seriously
satisfying bet these are traps for
secret agents when they get into your
lair right yes they are we shot off a
few last year we showed off the fan trap
the shark tank and the laser wall but
there's three new ones being shown here
this year we're showing off the fat trap
in game and also the boxing glove in
action if you look carefully you can
also see a large fake safe designed to
frustrate thieves and an array of poison
darts players will be able to chain
these however they want to create unique
trap combinations that really destroy
any agents who comes hunting through
their there
[Music]
so for fans of the series this is
actually the return of Maximilian as the
evil genius yes it is this is Maximilian
as super villains go he's pretty much
with the gold standard we've also
brought back a red Ivan who's a henchman
in the first game giving him a bit of a
promotion turned him into a genius of
his own right and there's some extra new
blood in there too we have two of the
geniuses who we'll be talking about at a
later date
intriguing speaking of intriguing
doomsday devices what can you tell me
rich I mean what's a villain without a
villainous plan every villain needs a
doomsday device and you can't really
call yourself a villain if you don't
have one
each genius has their own doomsday
device tailored to their own unique play
style we'll be talking more about those
in the days to come but they each have
their own distinct power and every time
you fire it at the world you'll be
making a giant enormous impact thank you
so that's everything you need to know
about taking over the world in evil
genius - now it's time for rebellions on
evil genius for a development update
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to evil genius to world
domination I'm excited to tell you that
the original composer James Hannigan of
evil genius is returning to the same
duties on evil genius to world
domination thank you Jason and hello my
name is James Hannigan
you may have heard my music before
within series such as Harry Potter
command & Conquer dead space theme park
runescape and of course the original
evil genius I have created a new stylish
soundtrack for evil genius - here is a
preview
[Music]
[Music]
I can't wait to tell you more about this
wait for now it's back to you Jason
[Music]
coming up soon on the rebellion official
twitch stream is more exclusive content
there's more coming on the run-up to the
release of the game there's going to be
some free content for the online
community we're going to be doing game
streams we're also going to be doing
deep dives of the devs if you want to
follow more shenanigans as we build up
to the release of the game follow us on
twitter at evil genius
follow us on facebook evil genius game
and finally we'll be ending with the
closed beta which should be very
exciting before the game release before
you go I have a couple of missions for
you first of all don't forget to add
evil genius to to your steam wish list
secondly for free content sign up on
evil genius game comm and now we return
you to your non evil normal scheduled
broadcasting
[Music]
[Music]
we have to nuke the polls Amy the
terraforming plan could be shortened by
years it's worth the risk
I'm concerned that if we do this there
may be uncalculated consequences for the
colonies we live on Mars Amy what could
be riskier than that hopefully nothing
the nuclear bombs are working the ice
caps are evaporating future generations
will gaze at the Martian sunset upon a
blue ocean I can't believe it only if
the temperature is high enough Elia
Mars's wilderness won't give up as
easily then let's occupy the rest of
this rock
[Music]
and suffer the consequences
[Music]
exclusive
many years are spent searching for their
map amidst the ruins deep beneath the
sands where Powerforce secrets of an
ancient river online powers are
forgotten god's corrupted kings
dangerous
yes but powerful Oh most certainly
fortunes have been forged and ruined
with their mine and those who dare to
face the bearer of such powers may all
fall
[Music]
have you come to claim the true power of
the armored Captain sex upper slaver of
the Seas servant of the source King I
seek my fortune my glory
[Music]
I am no witch the spores do this to
betray me some cost you everything and I
will not stop until I find him all the
hidden relics of Ritalin
[Music]
[Music]
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one of my favorite RPGs ever persona 4
golden is back and now on PC for the
first time ever actually its personas
first time ever on the PC and it
features English and Japanese audio
options just look at these
high-definition graphics and the
gameplay looks smoother than ever in
persona 4 golden you play as a high
school student who gets involved in a
series of bizarre murders just like all
of us after he discovers the mysterious
midnight channel on TV set to the
backdrop of the countryside in Japan the
entire story is just about the bonds of
friendship confronting your inner self
and of course Nanako protect her at all
costs anyways the game is out now on
Steam go get it
[Music]
everybody I'm northernlion and I'm
excited to be introducing for you a crop
of brand spanking new games you know as
a youtuber I've long held the belief
that really the only reason I'm able to
do my job is because of the hard work of
the talented folks who present their
games at events like this they spend
months or even years of their lives
locked in their office working their
wizardry on stuff like design code our
community QA and so on and then people
like me come in and for 30 minutes we
play it and go it's good you know we
have it really easy and we have it easy
because of the hard work of people that
are presenting their stuff today so of
course I jumped at the opportunity to
come in and help and introduce the games
and secondarily I want to encourage you
if you like what you see today tell the
people who made it that you liked what
you saw I'm sure they'd love to hear it
for now let's check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
world premiere army is quick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I hope you're ready please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
every day is something new
when my day begins with you
we've got everything we need as long as
I've got you and you've got me
[Music]
if you down need a friend
[Music]
I'll be there to hear
[Music]
sir
[Music]
whatever comes our way wait oh sure
obey me
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I just want to
[Music]
exclusive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you made it it's me professor shouts and
Nina get in the research station cozy
so now what we really need is a close-up
of this screw you it's - we found them
in treetops and rocks anywhere really
when you see the skull on your TV print
it out and fax it to me got it
great the neuro set toxins
what the is that what I think it is
seems like things have only gotten
stranger and stranger and mammoth
forests over the last three years we
have a work cut out for us
hey friends I'm Danny O'Dwyer from
noclip the crowdfunded YouTube channel
that makes documentaries about how video
games are made all of us here at noclip
really appreciate the enormous effort
that goes into creating video games and
one of the things we've learned over the
years is that one of them are
challenging aspects of game creation for
Studios is actually getting their
finished game in front of players
eyeballs so I just want to take a moment
to thank you all for watching the
guerilla collective show shall we keep
the show going all right here's some
more new footage from some amazing teams
enjoy world premiere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone it is Baron creative
director from run wild entertainment and
we're here to talk about or might be
kill your gods in Almighty you take the
role of an alpha a magical warrior and
fixes the power of your ancestors you
are reborn to protect your tribe against
the tyranny of the Elder Gods almighty
is non line action RPG with a fluid
approach to co-op multiplayer you can
choose to play solo with friends for
random players that you meet you are
equipped with power gold nuts which are
your magical weapon pythons you can
finish these with power stones that
provide magical abilities and on your
back an amulet that you can charge the
trigger epic spells you can double jump
and glide like a mystical ninja where
you can sprint on all fours like a beast
and charge headfirst at the bow on slam
down on enemies with your metal fists
shoot balls of lightning globs of
healing magic summon meet your storms
and much more the character class is
determined by your own unique play style
and the choices in how you equipped your
character the goal is to become almighty
and rebuild your home island by hunting
and looting in the enemy patrol lands
you'll need youth drop from fallen
enemies found in chests buried
underground and minerals sitting in the
environment your kindred will need
rescuing and can be found helping in
enemy territory when slave nor nefarious
reasons the biggest rewards come from
big kills they can down giant monsters
of gods means taken on various body
parts to convert the resources the real
challenge in securing your loop is to
activate magic portals that transfer it
back
this won't go unnoticed by the monsters
and gods the islands react dynamically
and the more you anger the gods of the
island the more trouble you will face
when you reach Ange the home islands you
can use that loop the repair and upgrade
buildings and the further have grade
your character upgrading and customizing
your home island allows you to do
several things
add defenses the protector I learned
from enemy attacks upgrade farms mines
to boost your economy build an
impressive tower of MAPE that directly
boosts your character's health and magic
stats eventually you'll be able to open
trading routes with your friends and
visit each other's home islands to help
each other to upgrade you can provoke
enemy raids onto your Island invite your
friends to health and face off together
the waves of powerful force and share in
the loop that was a brief overview of
our game or might be kill your gods
thank you for your time
[Music]
let's get going
now
I'm taking the lead
[Music]
don't mind if I do
mr. t cover me got it
are you okay you go girl I got your back
sweet oh no you are you all right
wanna see something too
[Music]
ah
a drone parking platform I was wondering
why we hadn't seen one yet
it doesn't look in too bad a shape yeah
it must have fallen to the ground when
it's gyro stabilizer ran out of flow uh
weren't you just looking for one of
those a gyro stabilizer uh I was but I
need a gyro stabilizer designed for
flight not a ground-based gyro
stabilizer what's the difference well
first of all the flight gyros cost three
times as much and secondly Oh Pluto
I think I'd be getting scammed my whole
life Oh at least this one is free so are
we bringing it home we're bringing it
home
[Music]
you
let me know if I can help
[Music]
rate oaks from little acorns grow
[Music]
all right give me those medical plants
of yours I'm gonna fire up the
synthesizer with this thing we'll be
right back on her feet are you sure you
know how I have a synthesizer in my ship
of course I know how these work uh no
wait that's not the way I know what I'm
doing really because at this stage you
should uh look I've always done it this
way and it's always worked out you're
not gonna tell me how to use my own
synthesizer all right all right as you
wish
ha ha there what do you say about that
all right
I didn't know you could also do it that
way and sorry I doubted you and I love
you ok
that's not what I was expecting but
it'll do
[Music]
funny story a lot of people on the
internet call me trash tailor they just
leave off the sailor part anyway each
and every one of us probably has a
beloved memory of an adventure game
whether it be riding our motorcycle in
full throttle saving Clem in the walking
dead or cursing Tim Schafer's name let's
check out a bunch of games that hope to
make you scratch your head before a
Eureka moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's been a murder last night
Paradise was killed
I am investigation Creek lady love dies
reporting for duty it's my job to scour
the streets of paradise than hunt for
evidence any one of these Psychopaths
could have done it breathing life back
into paradise won't be easy when love
dies all that remains are the facts
paradise killer coming soon
[Music]
what's up Justin from the mix and once
again I want to thank you all for
supporting the gorilla collective our
idea here is to support developers of
all shapes and sizes and make it so that
you can find your next favorite game I
want to thank our partners too who
submitted so many games partners like
Humble games who brought you all of
these gems
[Music]
[Applause]
kindling with a father
[Music]
[Music]
our squad is locked and loaded
I was just another girl from the country
in love I follow the boys promises to
Polly and I was abandoned but I chose to
stay to live for myself and seek my own
passions without you it was challenging
at first so many parties by so many
people who two cops who to snub soon I
had pawns of my own tailors bodyguards
and spies
my style is izing and quickly but I made
a single false step yet my story didn't
have two indexes it could have been so
much more
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a creeping curse that swallows whole
fall and broke and lost control and now
a choice is in your hands the ring of
pain and its demands
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now ladies and gentlemen a very
special treat
Chris Charla from ID at Xbox is here hey
Chris hey how's it going good man how
are you are you enjoying the show so far
yeah show is awesome and yeah I'm having
fun
you're a liar you haven't even seen it
yet but I appreciate it ah Chris for
those who don't know what is ID an Xbox
so ideally Xbox is a program that we
have at Microsoft that helps people
independent developers get their games
onto Xbox and other Microsoft platforms
and we provide things like obviously
platform access and free dev kits but
also promotional support like some
business analytics everything we can to
help developers succeed and just be able
to focus on the game while we help take
take some of the other weight off their
shoulders and that's one of the things
I've loved about you guys have been
around for seven years now and the
amount of Indies you've helped I mean
making a game is tough enough but then
trying to enter the fray of publishing
it marketing it getting all these
different things out there you're there
to help and that's amazing I have to ask
is ID at Xbox continuing into the Xbox
Series X generation we are yeah
absolutely we we already got Xbox Series
X dev kits out to developers we're
sending tons more out this summer and
that we've actually announced a few
titles scorn medium call the C we all
showed as Xbox Series X optimized games
those are all actually also going to be
launching into Xbox game past day and
date which is super cool so yeah like
we're like full steam ahead on next gen
Chris you brought a bunch of idea at
Xbox games to show us right now what's
the standout one to you man they're all
pretty cool I will call out a couple I
just I think dead static drive is really
really neat from Mike black me and the
guys at team fan club
it's from Melbourne Australia and I
would almost say it's kind of got that
Melbourne look it's really stylized kind
of pastel II is it's gorgeous and super
super fun to play well then Chris thank
you for your time thank you for all the
service you give the industry yeah
thanks for having me I'm super stoked to
see the event and ladies and gentlemen
here's a bunch of ID and Xbox games
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi I'm Megan and this is skatebird it's
a game about trying your best
now why skateboarding birds in
particular I came across a gif of
skateboarding like actual skateboarding
birds a couple of years ago and it blew
my mind I like birds just in general and
the skateboarding birds was like holy
jeez I grew up in the 90s playing
skateboarding games and essays genre
they just kind of stopped existing and
that's lame like I love these so I'm
making one because they're awesome and
I'm hoping that I can share some of what
kidney loved about them with you when
skate bird comes out in early 2021 and I
really hope you'll enjoy it
[Music]
in spell break players battle across the
hollow lands to become the ultimate
battle mage equipping magical gauntlets
you engage an epic spell casting combat
weaving spells together to defeat your
foes throat giant boulders shock them
with lightning strikes cast a giant
firewall or snipe enemies from afar with
iceland's you can even combine your
elemental spells like toxic cloud and
flame wall to roast your enemies with
dragon fire you'll also be able to take
your fight to the skies with unique
movement abilities to change the often
vertical battlefield fly - and teleport
across the map to take on other breakers
while snow breaks easy to learn it has
endless depth making it the perfect
showcase for your skills and play making
moments you define how you play to your
class talent and loot choices snow Brook
is releasing later this year see you in
the hollow and the Falcon air is an open
world air combat game where you play as
a mounted warrior on top a giant bird of
prey it's fancy twist on dogfighting
and air combat focusing you on your
really fast and agile turning battles
which you take on a variety of the
testicle enemies such as warbirds giant
airships pirate ships and of course the
Uzi equivalent of dragons the or Z being
the fantastical setting for this game a
bleak and fast ocean world full of tall
ships and hearty sea foam
you'll be a part of all these struggles
but you'll also be trying to uncover the
dark secrets that are hidden meet the
waves of the University
[Music]
The Forgotten City is an open world
murder mystery in an ancient Roman city
caught in a time loop in it you'll
discover the ruins of an ancient
underground city travel 2,000 years into
the past and talk to its inhabitants
you'll learn about a mysterious divine
law called the golden rule under which
if even one person commits a sin
everyone dies somebody in the city is
about to break that law and it's your
job to figure out who and stop them
fortunately for you when disaster
strikes you can race back to the time
portal from which you emerged and
restart the day over again retaining
everything you've learned and collected
exploiting this time loop allows you to
foil assassination plots avert fatal
accidents and much more The Forgotten
city has multiple endings so your
decisions matter the fate of the city is
very much in your hands trash they lose
as a co-op game about sailing on a
slapdash raft we have local and online
multiplayer of up to four people so you
can create the most disorganized team in
sailing history after years of ocean
pollution a giant trash tsunami flooded
the planet you are the castaways on a
small raft in the middle of nowhere now
you have to travel across the ocean and
find yourself a new home you are the
trash sailors that will need to steer
fight repair and get resources usually
at the same time garbage is your main
resource and the most valuable thing in
this world the game has awesome
hand-drawn graphics a lot of trash
places to visit and tons of enemies
trash tailors is coming out in 2020
call of the sea is a first-person
adventure puzzle game set in the 1930s
in the far reaches of the South Pacific
you take the role of Nora
a woman who has cross an ocean in the
shirt of her husband listen expedition
we had the lack of cabinet recipients at
the Poisson Nora we adored her active in
five words and her ability to create a
strong presence with only her voice it
is a tale of self discovery and
exploration not only of the island but
of the characters inner self we have
crafted beautiful scenes that you will
have to explore to put the pieces of the
story together puzzles will feel like
something that will push the narrative
forward and never hinder your progress
the island will hold many secrets that
you will have to UM Bay explore ruins of
a forgotten civilization and occult
mysteries
dead stetic drive we describe the game
as grand theft cthulhu that's a horror
survival adventure game you're traveling
through small town America making your
way home and making money where you can
the places you visit a strange and
getting stranger make friends get money
find places to stay young ways to eat as
your friends start to disappear they're
replaced with twisted creatures and it
becomes clear that more than just your
survival is at stake we give you a car
now scavenge for things you'll need to
survive things you'll need to build and
things you'll use to hunt monsters but
don't get too comfortable unless you've
got friends to look out for you
[Music]
welcome to earth is a story game with
lots of unique design minigames you play
as a young woman called Flik who travels
to the island of ELQ where everyone you
meet has a story to tell some stories
allied had other stock and tragic but
all of them come from true stories told
by my brother Logan and my parents from
the travels to places like Greenland in
welcome to earth you will also meet the
people who told the stories we use in
the game welcome to earth is a mystery
where the fourth wall will be broken
down and you will like Frick in the game
find yourselves somewhere between truth
and tortillas you can choose to believe
what you want but we made this game
based on real people thanks Chris and
thanks for coming by and reminding us
all that people make these games I know
that might sound silly but we all get so
caught up in review scores backlogs and
moving on to the next big title but I
think it's easy to forget the thousands
of people who work late nights and long
hours so their vision can be achieved
and we can be entertained in fact let's
hear from a few of our friends from
wings as to why they make games we
you may have heard about for the GDC
believe on with the help of our amazing
sponsors we have raised over two hundred
and ninety thousand dollars and helped
about two hundred indie developers
recoup their travel costs that was just
a cyclist our main mission is best
awesome games by women and developers of
marginalized background rings is
creating opportunities to bring more
diversity to the game industry here are
some of the pros and games and
developers
[Music]
[Applause]
don't forget me it's a narrative
memories investigation game that could
be a variable density the gameplay mixes
up a madman to game and a search for key
world in the cyberpunk world ruled by a
one-party government
everyone has an implanted chip set to
codes and memories memories that you can
explore in a clinic with a mansion
later daters was interesting to us
because we thought that seniors and
older people are left out of the
dialogue of what it is to be passionate
and to be in love and to feel the need
for connection like we just don't see it
portrayed very often in a way that
sympathetic or in a way that's sexy
charming I get through with really
lovely and supportive people a little
bit though I have tons of fun thinking
of crazy ideas Jer meetings while dating
Sims and visual novels are still a
fairly niche form of gaming its audience
is extremely passionate and it's been
really nice to see as the game has been
launched it embraced by that community
by the queer community for its
heartwarming and wholesome message
you play as Lord winklebottom the
gentleman giraffe detective and you're
aided by your companion dr. Reginald
from fort the hippo you're tasked with
solving the murder of your old school
friend
Admiral guilt-free the axolotl I've
always been a big fan of murder
mysteries and I wanted to bring a new
twist to the classic genre the game was
initially funded with a successful
Kickstarter in 2019 and Wheels has
helped increase my funding which will
help improve the game to admit even more
mushy and bullying Blokland is a
competitive arcade game in which you
have to push blocks to defeat monsters
you can also match three blocks of the
same color to get a powerup there are
five themed worlds with unique monsters
and at the end of each world there is an
epic boss fight we decided to make this
game when Nintendo announced the
Nintendo switch we wanted to make a game
that could be fun to play by the whole
family and it had to be cooperative
since the console already has two
controllers attached
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is Forrest Dowling and I'm
the creative director on Drake Hollow
today I'm gonna be giving you a first
look at some campaign gameplay let's
check it out
[Music]
all right so I'm just coming back to
base now I've been off exploring I found
this seed that was left for me long ago
and basically my job now is to bring it
back and have my friend Billy whiskers
here transform it into an actual weapon
that I can use so I'm just gonna talk
with him report back
he's sort of this mystic who's maybe a
charlatan but it seems like you might be
able to get this job done
right so he told me I could just need to
start the ritual so first I'm just gonna
take a quick look around so this is
really the core of what this game is
about is building these bases you see
some Drake's running around I've got
pinball machines and swing sets and
lobster tanks and water tanks and
windmills all just kind of providing
food and water and entertainment for
them and beds and places to sleep so we
do use 2d cutscenes throughout the game
to advance the story you know for
sequences that might be a little too
complicated to justify doing with all in
engine 3d assets so Billy's doing his
dance here transforming the seed into a
weapon I can use
but it looks like that's got the
attention of the local feral
so raid is incoming just gonna get to
some high ground here and take a look
around I set up that jump pad just to
get me up on the bunk bed so I can get a
nice vantage point I'm gonna go to bow
and arrow and take a look alright so we
got a couple grunts rolling in right now
they're going straight for the Tesla
coil but actually the teeth will a set
up next to it and the Tesla coils gonna
give me a lot of help taking out those
guys
he has attacking the wall to try and get
through but I'm just gonna get his
attention
I'm really not paying nothing it's just
Here I am kind of getting pretty beat up
I'm just gonna try and cut these guys
over to this Tesla coil because it's
gonna help me out a lot
they've got decoys to keep them busy
they've got Tesla coil to do damage
so those things you're hearing those are
the proximity mines that are dropped by
the fangs for Kennedy's ranged
area-denial enemies I've got a straggler
over here
[Music]
I am not doing great I'm gonna run back
like a coward to my Tesla coil again and
let it do some work for me because I am
really on death's door here all right
this guy's just lurking I gotta do some
oh and the last wave it is the terminer
of this guy and yeah he said hello Wow
all right I'm just gonna revive here and
takes a little bit of a durability hit
let's say it's a little time all right
I'm gonna go back to high ground and
look for this guy all right there is
this kind of lurking I'm gonna say how
little right back I don't have a lot of
arrow so I really can't do this for too
long I try and reflect his shot back at
him
all right so this summit is one of many
attacks this guy's got I can't hurt him
until I take out these goons I'm just
gonna drop a decoy I want to keep them
busy and around this other Tesla coil
I've got
and eventually they won't decide that
you're more interesting than a decoy but
it's a good way to draw enemies into a
specific location known to try and do as
much range stuff what this guy is
possible because he's got some really
heavy close-range attacks
but I am gonna run out of ammo
pretty soon here yep there we go
that's my balloon launcher but I only
have a couple of balloons
here's another one of his attacks he
drops these brambles around and they
just become obstacles that can clutter
up the battlefield
all right I'm sort of looking what I've
got what's got durability what's got
ammo down to a couple shots all right
it's mainly time
flecked that shot back
perfect he just walked himself right
into that Tesla coil this is really
gonna help take them out I'm getting up
there he goes all right the other one
took care of it and here is a chest that
spawns at the end of a raid just to give
me some good loot and reward me for my
troubles so there you have it that is
the first look at Drake Hollow campaign
gameplay we're coming out on July 17th
and we're coming to xbox one steam and
the Windows 10 store thanks so much for
watching
we're almost done for the day but before
we go what if we took a stroll around
the world while 2020s been a trash fire
you can't deny that the ease of sharing
art and experiences is great so we
thought what better way to close out day
2 of the guerrilla collective than with
a slew of announcements from some
Studios around the world you are the
president
[Music]
lead the country into ruin or repair
will you honor your election promises
the country's future depends on your
choices
how
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
exclusives
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
world premiere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and with that day two of the gorillas
collective is complete thank you to
everyone who submitted their games
talked about the industry and most
importantly watched we saw one more day
of demo starting tomorrow at 9:00 a.m.
Pacific
that'll be packed with deep dives devs
and gameplay but until then been our
pleasure to serve you the gorilla
collective thanks it's gold sponsor ID
at Xbox as well as all of these
supporting sponsors
you